un courrier électronique est couvert par
la loi sur le secret des correspondances
un email et donc un courrier secret
c'est le jugement rendu par un magistrat
du tribunal correctionnel de paris à
propos d'une affaire de violation de
correspondance cette décision pourrait
bien faire jurisprudence explications
avec david boeri et jean-françois chevet
l'e-mail au palais de justice un procès
d'un nouveau genre pour la première fois
quelqu'un porte plainte pour violation
de courrier électronique et le tribunal
lui donne raison dans ce cas là il est
incontestable que dans la sphère de
monsieur alba ou sa correspondance
électronique
tout a commencé ici en 1994 dans ce
laboratoire parisien de physique pendant
plusieurs mois
un étudiant est soupçonné par ses
professeurs de faire disparaître des
fichiers informatiques de recherche pour
s'en assurer la direction va finir par
fouiller sa messagerie électronique sur
son ordinateur
l'étudiant n'est bien sûr pas au courant
c'est justement ce que condamnent le
tribunal depuis trois ans déjà on fait
signer à tous les gens qui font de tel
chez nous à l'ouverture du compte un
formulaire disent qu'ils sont au courant
que n'ont pas le droit d'utiliser les
soucis donc il peut plus et ce qu'ils
soient si bien qu arriver cette charte
la voici l explique noir sur blanc aux
étudiants et aux employés du laboratoire
ce qu'ils ont le droit ou non de faire
avec leur messagerie électronique un
outil informatique de plus en plus
répandu dans les entreprises
déjà 1 5 million d'utilisateurs en
france ce qui oblige les employeurs à
établir de nouvelles règles et surtout à
en informer leurs salariés et in fine et
celle de l'employeur qui décide
un site a donc donc à lui de réglementer
l'usagé de l'internet dans l'entreprise
la façon dont il pourra contrôler ou pas
contrôler l'activité du salarié et des
salariés les conditions dans lesquelles
pourrait ouvrir le courrier les
conditions dans lesquelles il pourra
utiliser les courriers comme mode de
preuve
un premier jugement qui devrait inciter
les universités comme les entreprises à
fixer et à respecter des règles
d'utilisation pour le courrier
électronique le